hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch chess finals
it's Fabiano Caruana versus magnus
carlsen after game 7 that we've shown in
the previous video
Fabiano retaliated then magnus again won
a game then Fabiano again retaliated and
now this is game 11 and game 11 as well
as game 12 our clutch games that means
that a win in this game is not worth one
point and it's not worth two points it's
actually worth three points so yes this
tournament is weird like that but
whoever wins at the next two games it's
it really goes you know a long way for
their further point count so without
further ado let's check it out we will
have another rustling mode as we did in
Game seven but with a with a certain
twist so Fabi again goes for efore we
have c5 by Magnus Knight to f3 sorry
about that and now Knight to c6
we have Bishop to b5 again with the
rosula mo ND 5 again Magnus goes for the
same idea castles by Fabi Bishop to d6
again at the same as in game 7 and now
not a d3 light like in game 7 but the
immediate c3 making room for the bishop
on c2 and also just preparing to strike
in the center so crossing goes a sexy
kick kicks away the bishop we had brush
up to a 4 B 5 and Bishop the C to end
only now Knight G to e7 and there are a
few games were a 4 also d4 were played
but here D 3 by favi is a new move so
already as of move 8 we have a
completely new game so Magnus continues
he remembers the Knight to g6 grabs
control of the f4 square prepares the
castle Bishop to e3 by Fabi and now
Magnus castles King side and now at
night B to d2 so continuing development
Bishop back to e7 now similar to the
game 7 now you want to play d6 and start
developing your Queen side and now
Bishop back to b3 grabbing hold of this
diagonal but also preparing sorry about
that
sorry about that
it's amazing how the mailman always
arrives when I start recording
yeah but yeah Bishop to b3 preparing the
stuff to d5 to pin the night and it's
also very nice square for the bishop
since the C and E point have already
been pushed
we have d6 now and Bishop to d5 now
putting pressure on the knife here
Quinta eh defending and now
Fabi strikes in the center with d4s the
night is no longer included in the fight
for the d4 square so he capture seek
actress and now unpinning rook to b8 and
now rook the c1 Fabi brings the rook
inter game prepares captures and he's
hoping to win a pawn here and Magnus was
four nice to be four you could also
advance with c4 but for example the if
c4 then you do you do get a nice pawn
and c4 however you I can always
undermine it would be three and then you
will open up
well the C file for the rook so magnus
doesn't enjoy this so instead he goes
Knights two before he puts pressure on
the bishop however this does come with
the price of a pawn so the chapters on
c55 he goes after the pawn d captures
and now Bishop captures and c5 Fabi
grabs a pawn we have capture son d5
now Magnus wins the bishop so he does
was a pawn but he does get to the bishop
pair so ii capture son b5 and now Bishop
captures on c5 he gives up his bishop as
well rook captures on c5 and now Bishop
to be seven so here at Magnus is down
upon he no longer has the bishop pair
and he will try to create some sort of
an attack against the fabi's Depot now
is this a healthy pawn or is it a
weakness we will see so tonight the b3
by Fabi he wants to go night to the a5
to c6 and the night will be a just a
monster on c6 and if the black ever
wants to capture then white even gets a
nice pass born already on c6 so Queen d7
by Magnus are connecting rooks and now
Knight to a5 just going for that Knight
to c6 square with Bishop to a8 and now
Knight to cease
and of course you do not capture this
and allow this pointer to become a
monster here so rook bt 8 now as the
bishop moved magnus claims the e-file
and now at night f.2d for preparing
Queen to 3 Queen to f3 and Knight to f5
and the night will be extremely strong
there so Queen the six puts pressure on
the route but now a 5-bit defense it
just be four and now it's a very hard to
do anything about this whole central
structure as everything is so nicely
protected so here rook to e4 by Magnus
Magnusson wants to double up rooks on
the e-file and fabric continues as
planned with Queen to f3 preparing
Knight to f5
we have rook F the e8 and now Knight to
f5 s plan and here it's very dangerous
for black if you're not careful
for example Queen to c3 will put a lot
of pressure on blacks position so Queen
to d7 biphobia now Queen to c3 is
impossible as the knight would be
hanging here and there are a couple of a
couple of ideas that white could go for
here for example if Abby went for g3 he
wants g3 h4 and h5 however night the b8
here was extremely dangerous but then
again it's so complicated that there's
no way anyone would calculate this in a
rapid game but I will show it as it's
super interesting now for example if you
go somewhere like Queen to d8 then you
give up the a6 pawn so let's say you go
Queen to east Quinta is 7 to defend the
pawn now Quinta c3 is possible you go
after the pawn here f6 and now rook to
c7 with a double attack on g7 seems
completely winning for black however
black has Knight to f4 and now if you
move the Queen anywhere from the defense
of the rook here than just the Queen
captures rook and if you go for the
Queen then night Stewie to check wins
back the Queen King h1 Knight captures
on c3 and at the point is after rook
captures on a8 yes you are up a piece
however rook to e1 and the White has
back rank issues and now after night the
g3 defending you're gonna go tonight
capture Sun d5 attacking the b4 point as
well and after white defends it now
but rook captures Knight captures and of
course Knight to be six winning back
your piece the rook has to move rock a
person a 6-row capture some v6 and we
get this position where Fabi would end
up being up upon but it's of course like
I said a disgusting engine line no way
we see this this happen so g3 instead
preparing h4 h5 and Magnus goes for h6
now are creating some breathing room for
his King also preparing maybe Tori
maneuvered the night over to h7 @
shifted over to f6 or g5 if needed so h4
and now King to h8 most likely most
likely a waiting move but also maybe
just clearing the g8 Square for the rook
if you will at some point maybe need to
defend it
however knight back to e3 now no longer
the Jeep on is defended and now King
goes back to g8 now Magnus no longer
sees the need to keep the King on the
h-file rook F the c1 Fabi doubles up on
the C file now and now Knight back to f8
preparing 92 h9 to h7 so nice the f5
Fabi brings the denied back and now
Knight to h7 now the knight can be
shifted to f6 and you no longer need to
really need to worry about any g7
weaknesses and now King to g2 by Fabi
there was a knight b8 in the position
here but we're gonna we're gonna get
back to that so first Fabi improves the
position with King to g2 and Magnus
again goes Quinta King to h8 and now
Fabi does go for Knights to be eight and
now it's it's a very tricky idea because
here if you go Quinte 7 like in the
previous line Knight d6 just wins as
there's a double attack on the rook now
so not much you can do here also the the
2w looks and the C file are extremely
strong here so Fabi instead went for
Queen to d8 he keeps an eye on the d6
square but now Knight back to c6
again attacking the Queen Queen back to
d7 and Knight back to b8 now we have a
repetition of the position Magnus goes
back Queen to d8 and now
Fabi does go after the pawn Knight
captures on a6 and okay
Magnus goes for Bishop captures on d5
but
this doesn't doesn't really help him as
now Fabi just goes night back to c7 and
now there's a double attack on the
bishop here and also there's an attack
on the rook here and there's a well
there's not much you can do about all of
this so Magnus goes back with Bishop to
b7 you of course give up the exchange
you don't give up a piece Bobby grabs it
with Knight chapters on the 8th and here
if you capture the the rook the knight
for example with this then just Queen
captures here you don't want to give up
this bishop
so instead Magnus goes for not Queen
captures but rather rook to e7 first he
first wants to kick away the Queen and
only then recapture the night however
this doesn't really help Magnus so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the quickest way to win the game
for Fabi well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on parting
with your queen and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show its Queen
captures on b7 yes the the move that was
prevented by Brooke e7 is actually the
way to go so here a Magnus doesn't
really have any choice he has to capture
the Queen and now we have Knight e to d6
and now this is an excellent score for
the night guards this one the Knights
guard each other also you add more more
pressure to the c8 square so look to see
it is coming regardless of what you play
also if you try something like rook here
tonight characters on f7 check picks up
the Queen so here sorry and not this
night this night was played not that one
a knight e to D 6 was played but pretty
much with the same idea also guarding
this square if you move the rook the
knight chapters on f7 with check so here
in order not to allow any of this
Magnus play Knight to a fate to keep his
King safe but it was also in this
position unmoved 40 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game as now he hung a whole
rook on b7 so there was just too much
pressure and you couldn't just you know
fix fix everything in the position so
here after Knight captures on b7 White
has two rooks and two nights for for a
queen and the knight which is of course
completely winning and once this row
comes to see it it's it's just all over
yeah that's a game 11 at the clutch game
which means Fabi wins three points for
this game and which means a Fabi is now
in the lead in the finals of the clutch
just international and also this means
that Magnus must win the final game to
win the finals if not if the game is a
draw or Fabi wins the game 12 then Fabi
wins the entire event so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it
I'd like to thank Daniel Jones a
Christopher Hargrove a burette Gras
party peter jones and johannes the
Ritter for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing with the final game of the
clutch chest international where we will
see what will happen
sir thank you I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day